meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
ist ein schwert es gibt nur zwei rote
lesen 3 das ist so ungefähr so 3
3-ausgleich micro etwas näher halten
erfolgreich wegen sido wäre ohne sie nun
genauso erfolgreich gegen das noch nicht
aber es die frage na ja es geht ihr
darum ob wir nur wegen mutig maske und
schminke aller crowe und instinkt laut
seco peter nicht nur andere rapper ja
berechtigte frage natürlich
also insane clown posse kannte ich nicht
bis wir die schminke gemacht haben und
dann gehe heute gesagt habe ihr seht aus
wie die dann haben wir das entdeckt und
sie sehen halt einfach richtig scheiße
aus ich hoffe ich hoffe wir haben
niemals so ausgesehen wie die crew wir
waren vor crowe der war noch schneller
bekannt als wir natürlich vor
aber jetzt wir haben sozusagen
aufgefrischt und cro war nach uns aber
war halt schneller und dann muss man
halt leben ganz einfach kein besonders
schöne tier cooler eure masken oder
panda natürlich finden wir unsere masken
cooler aber groß auch kunden soll ich
sagen sollen dass das passt zu seinem
konzept und zu unserem konzept passt
auch fertig das kann nebeneinander
existieren dann nicht eine grüne nummer
rot fehlen
ok
vorlesen
gebt ihr jetzt erfolgende charts und
manch ein fan spricht von ausverkauf
hebt ihr jetzt ab willst du so was sagen
ich schließe mich an
wir heben nicht ab weil wir kriegen ja
davon nichts mit und keiner quatscht uns
voll mit ihr seid so cool und er hat es
voll drauf um so denn wir hier rausgehen
nach hause fahre ist alles wie vor
dreier und deswegen haben wir auch nicht
ob ich das wirklich wahr wann ist diese
entscheidung gefallen wir machen sind
maske zu wir haben zur großen aufmacher
gebraucht visuell und clown war der
stärkere tschuldigung und clown war der
stärkste trek und wir wollten clown
visualisieren dann haben wir an clown
entworfen und den beibehalten also es
gab gar nicht so die entscheidung waren
jetzt mit maske sondern das hat sich so
ein bisschen uns aufgezwängt cool und
gelassen wir haben nicht so viel darüber
nach dass wir haben es gemacht dann hat
uns gefallen so gut bleibt so ganz
einfach also das war jetzt mal
ausnahmsweise nicht ausgetüftelt von
anfang an aber wir haben es dann gemacht
war cool fertig und es liegt ihr euch da
einige war von anfang an schon warum wir
waren uns eigentlich von anfang an auf
jeden fall also ich hatte auch nie bock
mein gesicht irgendwie der
öffentlichkeit zu präsentieren
und er auch nicht okay dann wünsche ich
dass das weiter bleibt dass er euch
weiterhin so einig sein und euch
nicht irgendwann mal dramatisch in die
haare kriegt wegen einer
grammatikalischen das kann passieren
aber wir versuchen sie basieren campus
ii ok dann drücken wir die daumen dass
es nicht passiert danke ok und viel
erfolg und danken ohne weile auf der
eins und so weiter und so fort